[Music]
tonight an update to a story we brought
you earlier this week about an American
family with two members being held in
Iran national security correspondent
Jennifer Griffin tells us the u.s. is
demanding Iran release an 81 year old
American had put back in prison this
week after giving him a four-day leave
for health reasons family of eighty
one-year-old Beaucaire namazi says he is
a political pawn along with his son
Semak an American businessman imprisoned
by Iran after the nuclear deal in a
cruel twist the Iranian regime released
back hair for four days because his
health was failing this week they sent
him back to Iran's notorious Evin prison
I was stunned
when the prison officials out of the
blue called my mom and demanded that my
father report back immediately
but Kanimozhi son Baba grew up in White
Plains New York and his lobbying
Congress in the White House for help he
said his father faces a virtual death
sentence and described his brother's
torture in solitary confinement
he's been shocked by by tasers that
wires have been
tight with him with threats of electric
shock
we're deeply disappointed in the fact
that he has been returned to prison
were concerned about his health we call
for his unconditional release from his
unjust detention in Iran but Kanimozhi
was lured back to Tehran during a visit
abroad with the promise of seeing his
son in prison three years ago while on
vacation in Iran I have no doubt that
that being Americans is a reason that
have entertained baccarat namazi worked
for UNICEF for more than two decades his
colleagues released a statement after he
was sent back to prison this week we
continue to be very concerned about his
deteriorating health and plead with the
Iranian government to grant him a full
and unconditional release on
humanitarian grounds
the new mozzies are not the only
Americans being unjustly detained by
Iran there is Princeton graduate student
Xie Wang and another American Quran
vapid ari who ran an art gallery in
Tehran was just sentenced for 27 years
because of his religious identity
President Trump has vowed to impose
sanctions on Iran if these American
prisoners are not released immediately
Kris Jenner / thank you